won't you be my neighbor is a new
documentary that's about the life and
times of Fred Rogers famed host of
Mister Rogers neighborhood a program for
children that was run unlike any other
program for children at the time and
ever since to be honest for those who
don't know Mister Rogers neighborhood
was a show that featured Fred Rogers
teaching life lessons to children around
the entire world but he spoke to
children with intelligence despite the
fact that he would sometimes use puppets
and characters to communicate his
thoughts he never talked down to
children he spoke to them as equals he
expressed thoughts that were far more
complex than your average television
show host even for an adult show and
this was one that was aimed at children
I was concerned though that it would be
very fawning and perhaps just talk about
all the great things that Mister Rogers
did and oh he's so wonderful and I was
very pleasantly surprised to see that
the film does dive deep into a very
complex man a man with a lot of fears
and worries
this documentary paints Fred Rogers as
an artist dealing with a lot of
insecurities now if you've ever been one
of those then you know how that feels
and he was someone who used his puppet
characters to communicate how he felt
according to his wife in this
documentary that puppet was mostly Fred
and that kind of just really got to me
especially when it would show certain
sequences in his show and you understood
that he was really letting us know how
he felt it was almost like a coping
mechanism for Fred Rogers but by far the
aspect of this documentary that floored
me the most that I never picked up on
when I was a kid is that he would
communicate very serious issues through
his show to help kids cope and
understand when a national tragedy
occurs there is an episode about
assassination and what the word
assassination means when a news story
hit about a man who was throwing
cleaning chemicals into a pool because
the pool was allowing white people and
black people mr. Rogers had
episode where he sat in a wading pool
with mr. Clemmons who was a black man
and just sat there and they bathed in
the wading pool together and they sent a
message out to the world a message that
kids can understand or at least
subliminally pick up on and that floored
me in this dock those intricacies in his
program showed just how much he really
did care about children and treating
them like they were the special people
he knew they all could be the
documentary also doesn't shy away from
showing the criticism that Fred Rogers
faced later in his life because a lot of
people felt that his message that any
kid was special was detrimental to the
fact that kids they didn't feel like
they had to do anything because they
were just special didn't have to put
forth effort obviously this is a very
silly criticism but it was in newspapers
it was on the news this was a big thing
there were parodies obviously one of the
ones I always loved was Eddie Murphy on
SNL and there's a clip in the dock of
Fred Rogers showing a photograph of him
and Eddie Murphy and so you can tell he
was sort of okay with that one probably
because it aired later at night and kids
couldn't necessarily see it and be
affected by it in some way shape or form
but it was other parodies of himself
that he felt very uncomfortable with
because he was afraid that children
would see that and then think that that
was okay where he really dedicated his
entire life to trying to reach children
and and teach them things that he felt
was very important that could help them
in their lives and I just found this
film so emotionally touching being able
to understand his life message there's a
letter that he wrote later in life where
he felt like he was conflicted on
whether or not he really had it in him
anymore if he was really reaching kids
he felt like maybe the world was just
getting worse and you look around today
and you wonder if maybe he was right and
it's a very timely and I think necessary
message for people to see because this
guy spent his whole life trying to
achieve something and you look at today
and you wonder did he it briefly covers
his child
and some aspects of it the fact that he
was an ordained minister which I
honestly did not know and that he didn't
necessarily believe that wearing a
collar as a priest would be the most
effective way to reach kids because he
felt that perhaps the religion might get
in the way of it so that was sort of his
way of preaching which honestly I had no
idea about all of that which was very
interesting to learn and so really this
documentary affected me on an emotional
level it taught me things about the man
I never knew and about his show I never
knew as a documentary this is about as
good as they come I do wish that it Dell
just a little bit more into his
childhood so we could understand his
psyche but through the letters that he
had written before that his wife talks
about and understanding just how
tortured of an artist really he was I
think this is one of the better
documentaries I've seen in a long time
I'm gonna give won't you be my neighbor
and a this is a terrific documentary
it's starting to expand into more
theaters and I highly suggest checking
it out even if you haven't seen his show
before or don't know that much about him
this is a fascinating portrayal of a man
that did a lot of good for a few
generations and I think his impact has
been very positive and I don't know if
we're ever gonna get another guy like
this so give it a watch guys thank you
so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get steppen eyes
[Music]